the jurogan experience
how was logan paul as a wrestler dude it
was i'm sure he's great yeah he's going
to be a wrestler oh he should be he's
like he's hard he's a star he's a star
his podcast is actually really good yeah
really the dana white up trying to get
on it or something well no the dana
white episode i looked at the whole
thing i listened to a clip yeah then on
yeah and it's great it's an amazing pod
episode
give it a give it a like he's done a lot
of [ __ ] man i mean you got to give the
guys props he's not lazy he fought floyd
mayweather in a boxing match i don't
care if he's 50 pounds heavier than me
it's still floyd [ __ ] maybe yeah
that's crazy look at that yeah dude whoa
he was doing splits and [ __ ] that was
pretty impressive
oh lucha oh my god damn he's a [ __ ]
athlete look at that flexibility yeah he
was is that a real lucha library thing
or is that just in yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like in mexico i
thought it was i had no idea he was that
flexible that's crazy
wow yeah good for him you ever seen
dalian wake up with him
makeup yeah because
he used to go at it and he's like hey
whatever i said before the guy's a star
forget it oh wow
wow what did dalia used to say about him
he's just like [ __ ] this idiot [ __ ] this
kid who's like a influencer yeah but it
was like that was easy to do though i
know it's not really i was wrong this
guy's awesome him and his brother are
[ __ ] animals i mean what they've been
able to do is incredible his brother
knocked out tyron woodley
with one punch that's crazy out bro
he's like a vicious vicious a striker
he's not a wrestler he's a striker well
he was a wrestler oh he would just have
power but but the fact that he knocked
out one of the greatest welterweight
champions of all time with one punch is
[ __ ] bonkers and it was
oh
watch this watch this oh i did see that
okay jake
that sucks being sponsored by dude wipes
calm the [ __ ] off yeah right when you
get knocked out
all of a sudden the sponsors are when
you feel kind of embarrassing and you're
showing that sponsorship dude
couldn't you fall backwards face plant
with dude wipes in your butt see he's
got the power out of the two of them
like logan
logan is a really good athlete but he's
not as good of a boxer but jake paul on
top of being a better boxer he's got
like legit power tyron took it on like
just a few weeks notice and there's no
way he was conditioned for that fight so
when you're not
like fully camp conditioned you take
breaks like and you're in the fight like
there's times where maybe you should
move and you go i'm just going to take a
[ __ ] break here and you're like
trying to like gather up your energy and
you manage it over the course of the
three minutes you can't just go out like
when you see like if you see a fighter
like manny pacquiao when he's in his
prime and he's [ __ ] supremely
conditioned there's no
thought about conserving energy manny's
just thinking about how to [ __ ] you up
just thinking about how to [ __ ] you up
because his conditioning is off the
charts i mean he's not going he's not
sprinting he's conserving some energy
but that's not his primary concern his
primary concern is just like hitting you
when a guy gets to a point where
you know most likely he's not training
every day hard when he doesn't have a
fight scheduled then he gets a fight
schedule and it's only two weeks notice
you can kind of get in shape in two
weeks but not not like the kind of shape
you need to be able to find
so he was taking a break because he also
must have thought like it's not an mma
guy it's a paul he already fought him
lost but there there were moments in
that first fight where he was playing
and tyron would turn it on he was he's
the better dominated it would have been
a different fight if tyron had the time
to prepare i guarantee you i guarantee
you because he would have more
conditioning more confidence to hit the
gas like when you don't have condition
if you don't have a full camp you you
still are in shape you're a [ __ ]
professional athlete he's still a
[ __ ] stud of a man but he doesn't
have the the kind of conditioning that
you need to go a hard fight when you you
know you you you condition your body
three minutes re three minutes hard work
one minute rest three minutes hard work
one minute rest world work plyometrics
you get conditioned he's not there's no
way he was conditioned but that's part
of their attack is i think people
underestimate
and that's how they come in
everybody the the wrestler guy the real
wrestler whatever everything we got
knocked out
asgrin asgrin yeah all these guys like
whatever you're not like you guys are
actually working hard i actually i
actually think ashgren didn't give a
[ __ ] right i actually yeah he looked
joey i dude well
listen asking had a hip replacement he
took the fight after hip replacement and
not that long after hip replacement
there's no way he was in shape for that
fight and aspirin i don't
[Music]
does tyron really make more in those two
fights than his whole ufc career
supposedly most likely wow
yeah i don't know what the number is wow
yeah i like those polls it's kind of
like the youtube comics
they offered he offered chris rock and
will smith 40 million dollars who did
paul
jake paul did christopher was like i
don't have any i don't care about wilson
well not well even if he did chris
rogers it's very small it's not fair
right the difference is like 60 pounds
he never trained to play the greatest
boxer of all time right
will smith put up will smith as muhammad
ali dude will smith is a [ __ ]
athlete because he when he was playing
muhammad ali it was one of those rare
moments there's like
a few guys that have pulled it off
daniel day lewis did a great in the
boxer
mark wahlberg did it great to the
fighter when he played uh mickey ward he
did a fantastic job but show the video
of him moving around because there's
video from the fight
and he was [ __ ] good man that's crazy
that picture of him taking the robe off
literally he got like the kind of still
baby fat but jack like ali exactly like
ali did he did a fantastic job as ali
and that's him against sunny liston
cinematography yeah but he's a good
athlete man i think it's a michael
that's why this is so not fair like it
is
this to have
a boxing match between this man and
chris rock is crazy yeah
you